in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Chris
and Amanda are with us hey guys how are
you good Dave how you doing better than
I deserve welcome where you guys from
Bloomington Indiana Oh ones bit of a
drive to Nashville yeah for hours it was
all good not too bad not too bad so
you're here to do a debt-free scream yes
sir and how much have you paid off
forty-seven thousand nine hundred ninety
dollars and 23 cents love it and how
long did that take 31 months good for
you and your range of income during that
time we started off combined forty seven
thousand eight hundred nineteen twenty
and we actually in the middle of our
journey
she took off a year she got pregnant and
she's high-risk but we were told we'd
never have kids so during this journey
we had our little miracle lost awesome
yeah so there was a point where we
didn't make as much huh but we we've
ended up at 51 896 okay very cool very
cool and what do you guys do for a
living I work at cook medical and I work
at cook Formica okay and what's the
little miracles named Savannah Savannah
eldest way how old is Savannah now nine
months all right very cool so what kind
of debt was this $48,000 um we had 51:23
in credit cards um her car a mobile home
that I didn't know depreciated when I
bought it years ago it's alright there
you go and then about 32,000 and medical
and miscellaneous oh wow okay so what
happened at that thirty one month ago
mark before little Savannah was here
that made you guys wake up and say we
got to get out of that well story
actually started with me a little bit
before that um I used to I grew up in
the streets California and uh I really
wasn't living right and 2006 one of my
friends was murdered hmm and then in
2008 another one of my friends was
murdered good lord and it's riding
around kind of just thinking and I heard
this guy on the radio to know God and
money in and Here I am driving around in
a low
writer I was that cool guy at the
stoplight you'd never see again mm-hmm
and I just started thinking you're just
telling me how about integrity and an
honor and working hard and I'm hearing
all this and Here I am driving around
acting a fool no no life no no no vision
and you kind of saved me because you
pulled me out of that because I started
looking into the god thing and the money
and I started working and got away from
all that stuff that was going to end up
only having me in prison or dead myself
mmm Wow good for you man thank you you
are a hero I'm proud of that is very
neat so sorry but so you're in a church
now yeah we got we attend Hillcrest
Christian Church in Bedford Indiana
shout-out to Hillcrest alright Tom I've
also had the opportunity to correspond a
class there myself with one of the
alters Jeremy Fox Wow all very good I've
got to help other people learn how to do
this very cool and so your first job
after you decided to like straighten out
was what working at modus Link Global
Solutions and I was lucky enough to have
a couple of mentors there they saw the
passion in me and what I could be mm-hmm
and I've actually traveled this country
training facilities we were actually
hearing smearing at Tennessee two years
ago yeah helping out a facility to get
their Quality Control Department up and
running and now huh but we lost our
contract with that bad company mm-hmm
and in the middle of this we lost our
job even yeah so if it wasn't for us
paying off her car my mobile home we'd
have all kinds of payments Wow and it's
it's like everything has just lined up
perfectly to help us through God really
does see when you when you're doing
things the right way
Wow so you how long ago was lowrider
Chris then I sold my lowrider in 2011 is
that when you start straightening out
there yeah okay I had my first back
surgery I uh I've also almost died in
car wrecks twice 97 flip the car five
times at 90 no seat belt I suppose be
dead a quadriplegic 2003 I got hit by a
semi that ran a red light and we've been
told we'd never be able to have kids and
always especially my friends was
murdered I was like why am I still here
I just had this this uncontrollable why
am i here feeling you can you continue
to
proof miracles all around you yeah Wow
the things that can't be done you're
doing yeah ain't that a true I love it
man that's awesome
the main message though is for people
like me that are from the streets we
grow up with this demands against us
attitude and all this who LA and man if
you really buckle down and realize your
Worth and life and get out there and
prove who you are and what you can do
your limits are not there there is no
limitations what you can do you know and
those are the things I learned from you
on the radio was just like I said that
hard work and being a man that went up
to the plate and doing what you got to
do and quit being out there running
around on the streets you know
so that integrity and that honor that
God thing it all works it works where is
real it's real that's real well you're
walking proof I'll tell you that I'm so
proud of you man thank you sir I'm
honored to see you and talk to you this
is very cool what a great story your
life is you've done done some pretty
amazing things and Savannah's the best
oh yes yeah very cool and right next to
that would be Amanda yeah yeah tell you
what this woman is main thing the help
also get me straight now where did you
two meet
motus Lincoln okay all right cool cool
well very cool congratulations you thank
you thank you so after all of that
getting out of debts no big step when I
first got together um cuz we both come
from previous marriages
uh-huh um and she asked me to marry her
Dave we were already dating and I'm old
schools like nah know I gotta ask you so
I was like now I don't know about that
but I knew she was serious so I took her
to a financial peace class oh because I
wanted to do that anyway because I've
always been listening to you and that's
what started our journey in and I
finally got her to let you ask her yeah
yeah she had no clue David's awesome
lakeside balcony overlook and it was
great good for you well done well done
so how does it feel now to be completely
debt-free awesome it's amazing I mean
you guys are sitting you're sitting on a
platform now that ten years ago you
couldn't even have imagined with a new
baby careers are going up no payments in
the world you walk
with God in a good church it's a
completely different life you got yes
sir
you've completely transformed everything
you're impressive people absolutely
thank you
her previous marriage tell her I'm
telling about what your husband had you
in
well when for different reasons that we
had decided to separate but when we were
separating um he came out and said that
our house was in foreclosure and he
hadn't paid taxes for three years
oh my goodness so I was you know
completely oblivious to our finances I
had you know he handled it I thought and
then you'll never be there again yeah
and I swore I would never never be that
way again so when he approached me about
your program he was like we got to do
this we're doing this we're doing this
and I'm like whoa you know on a minute
so I was really skeptical at first and
some about meat on her cellar car yeah
yeah you were that guy he said he said
okay babe we're selling your car I'm
just like um no just we stuff yeah I was
using the wheat term oil done you guys
well done all right we've got to sign
the copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired book because I do want to talk
to you when you're millionaires because
you are going to be the symbol the great
American Dream that it can be done yeah
yes can be done walking with God with
honor and integrity being a man and and
a lady of character and you know these
things you know you've changed your
whole life you change your whole family
tree yeah and I say one more area
impressive yes sir I'm sorry to cut you
off when I first started this journey as
well the giving aspect I went to a gas
station one day and those his kid in
front of me looked tattered and uh he
came to the van he drove up in was real
beat-up and when they're in front of me
in the line he walked away it was five
quarters sitting on that desk day for
gasoline mmm and when I seen that I
looked at that cashier and I said you
know what man I had $40 left in our fuel
envelope I gave him 20 kept the other 20
and that was one of the things that
really turned the giving part around in
a whole nother level yeah because now we
try to help people you can't get much
this motion
on you ever happy it is awesome you know
alright Chris and Amanda Indianapolis
48,000 paid off in 31 months making 47
to 52 all the way from the streets to
here count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
we're debt free absolutely amazing
very well done you guys very well done
thank you thanks for being here you guys
absolutely incredible this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
Oh